when you come to this country you become
American and you're meant to assimilate
and and then arab-american for example
or italian-american becomes a new thing
there's Italians and then there's
Italian Americans and for me having
grown up largely in Manhattan on the
Upper West Side but going to a private
school which was mostly as I say in the
play wasps as a young girl I first of
all thought I was Jewish because I
didn't there were no other there were no
Jewish people and I looked different had
dark hair and lived on the west side so
I thought I was Jewish and also I didn't
seem to understand how I fit in with the
vision of an Arab that I saw a TV and in
the news and in movies and then again
and I didn't feel like I had any
identification with what was being told
what I was being told was an Arab
American so let's say there's a you know
there's a large community in Detroit and
Michigan of people who are whose
families came here generations ago that
are originally Syrian or Lebanese or
whatever and I didn't feel identified
with them so I didn't really understand
what this idea of being either
I wasn't Arab and I wasn't fully
American but I was somehow didn't feel
like I was Arab American so it was
confusing and also my parents you know
my father was an English professor so I
it didn't make sense that you know
nothing made sense and we were Christian
and not only Christian we were Quaker so
all of the things that I would hear
about what an Arab was I didn't fit any
of them and so it was difficult but I
find it was funny because when I was at
a school with mostly Christian people
even though I was Christian and I felt
really different and then I went and
switched schools and I went to high
school with mostly Jewish people and I
felt more comfortable and it's sort of
that funny thing of how because they
were Jewish and they knew about Israel
and what was going on in the Middle East
somehow I became able to know what it
meant to be Arab and
way in a more personal way and so I
suddenly began exploring and finding out
who I was but it was it was really
really confusing as a general
I found a way in because I started with
the premise of everyone thinks I'm
Jewish and so I this has been
misconstrued because people haven't seen
the play and then they they hear some
sensational thing about how I talk about
being Jewish and they get confused but
that I wasn't saying I am Jewish I was
saying I grew up in New York City on the
Upper West Side people have always
called me a Woody Allen character I tend
to when people meet me I tend to come
off as an Upper West Side New York
Jewish or Italian girl and in that sense
I use that to my advantage because the
first part of the play I talked about
how I grew up and then you know kissing
Jewish boys and you know saying Oliveri
and eating bagels and lox and and being
neurotic and going to the shrink when I
was ten and all of that stuff which is
very stereotypically like the Jewish
cultural Jewish New Yorker I used that
as a way for people to listen so once I
got the audience to listen then I start
saying ok but I'm really Palestinian and
Lebanese and I never I never I never
claimed to know more than anyone else or
I mean I think the struggle in and of
itself of trying to figure out where I
fit is what people relate to and in the
end someone said to me a friend of mine
who's Jewish it's a Jewish story which
was the ultimate compliment in the sense
that like you couldn't offend anyone so
on the other hand so on the one hand I I
managed to say a lot of truths about
what goes on in Israel and Palestine and
the Middle East in general but on the
other hand I was able to do in a
disarming way which I think you can only
get if you're born of two cultures
um the first part of the story is mainly
about my youth and I talked about this
first trip I went on to Palestine the
only time I've ever been there when I
was 18 in 1992 at the time I was very
sick and with an eating disorders
anorexic that part was less it was
difficult but it was less difficult than
some of the more recent stuff because it
was long ago and I've processed it and
been through in therapy and I'm better
so everyone thinks oh you're so brave
too but that part was really it was
difficult on a daily basis to rehearse
this period of you know who wants to be
18 again who wants to be an adolescent
again it was everything was miserable
and so dramatic and you don't want to go
through that again but on the other hand
it was nice to go back and just be like
I'm not this person anymore look how
much I've grown um but there and like
the more recent stuff like my father's
death I kept in rehearsal when we got to
the part where my father died I kept
skipping the section and going on to the
next one they were like go back you
after your father has to die and it's
chronological so it was you know it was
just this mental block in my head and
and I found that very very challenging
but I think what happened ultimately was
that I began to feel like my father was
on stage with me for the duration of the
performance so I tried to flip it so it
was like a positive thing that I was
with him for the whole hour and 40
minutes and I think that helped a little
but it was it was definitely difficult
and also one last thing was I spoke
about being in Lebanon as a nine year
old being bombed and then again in 2006
as a grownup being bombed and what's
interesting about that is that I didn't
really realize that I was traumatized as
a little girl until I was there in 2006
and I heard the bombs again and I had a
very sort of overwhelming seemingly
melodramatic
action which I guess is trauma or
post-traumatic stress so when we
recreated both of those events both
being bombed in Lebanon is an 8 year old
a 9 year old
and as a however old I wasn't 2006 I'm
really bad at math um I my reactions
were real and so he they made it very
clear because I may I say in the play
there's no way you can replicate the
sound of a bomb when it's real because
part of it is the psychological
knowledge that it's a bomb and the other
thing is that it's just louder and
scarier than anything you've ever heard
so they very consciously used a sound
cue that was like a drum you can tell
it's a drum but the loud noise really
really really scared me but then again
that was an advantage because I was
really scared every night so on the one
hand when you're retelling a story it's
you know it's it can be very emotionally
intense in a in a negative way but it
also serves you because you're really
able to relive it in a very pure way for
the audience so I think that that was
kind of great
I think one of the things that was
important to me was that it not be
dismissed as a shallow you know young
girl just wanting to be skinny so she
can be a model disorder I think eating
disorders are often misunderstood as as
mine was by my parents very much they
thought it was very selfish and but I
think that it was for me at least and
after many years of therapy I've been
able to put this together um for me it
was a combination of things um yes you
want to be thin but there's a reason you
want to be thin it's not I mean part of
it is to fit in and to you know I didn't
look like other people I had an Arab
body which was a had curves and I didn't
want them because no one else looked
like me so there was that and then on
another level on a deeper level it was I
didn't want to grow up which is another
part of in general anorexia you
literally don't want to grow up so you
make your body like an adolescent's body
um and I was just graduating from
college and the other was my father had
been diagnosed with leukemia and I think
we all do whether we get migraines or
ulcers or whatever it is we take
whatever stresses us out we put it into
our body and for me at the time I didn't
know how to express my fear and and my
just incredible sadness at my father's
diagnosis so I think part of me even
though he would get mad and say you know
I'm dying and you're killing herself
part of me and wanted to take on his
sickness and share it with him because I
didn't know how to express my sadness
and so there was there was a great deal
of wanting to suffer with him when I
went on this trip and I saw people
suffering in Gaza and I mean there were
two elements of the trip that I I I used
one was it was so such a Western thing
to not eat it's a very Western I mean
there are definitely women in the Middle
East who have eating disorders but the
idea of not eating or not enjoying life
or partaking in life was in many ways a
rejection of that culture which is so
much about food and love his food is
love and he and me going there and being
like I'm not eating was a very a very
sort of vivid example of me rejecting
the culture and then the other thing was
just going there and then adding you
know feeling all the feelings that I
felt about seeing people without food or
without water or living in huts in the
mud and feeling guilty so there was that
element which I sort of joke about being
sort of I wanted to be a Christ figure
in the Middle East so but all of that
stuff came to me years years later after
much therapy I did not know any of that
at the time it's not like when I'm
writing about myself as an 18 year old
wanting to suffer I had any
consciousness of that that was all years
of therapy and and growth but for me
personally the the journey out of the
anorexia was I mean I started seeing
doctors right then when I was you know
about to go to college they'd said I
shouldn't go to college I had to go to
the hospital and I refused so I did an
outpatient treatment and physically I
would gain enough weight to get my
period which is what they want you to do
in you're a girl and then I would go on
a diet again and lose it so that went on
for a few years and it wasn't until I
was studying acting seriously that I
began to actually physically and
mentally get better because I was taught
to breathe and to fill up with air and
let myself experience and I had to and
and my teachers like you're too skinny
you need you know energy and so there
was that and then the other the last
component of it was
I didn't I went to the Middle East as a
little kid I went when I was nine to
Lebanon and we left under bombs and I
didn't go back again until I was 18 when
I went back when I was 18 I was like
where is my my country like where's my
grandfather or where's my they they were
all dead and everything was bombed so
and I had spent like basically my
forward formative years from the age of
basically nine and a half until 18 with
no connection to the Middle East
and that's when sort of the anorexia
formed and as I began to go back to
Lebanon and become more and more
comfortable there and felt more a part
of something I was able to as I say in
the play was able to nourish myself so
yeah it took a long time but I I started
to feel like I was part of something and
so I felt the love of my family and
literally they nourished me with love
and food and I felt connected so I mean
obviously there are a lot of things but
I think for me that was really important
because it was like I was able to find
an identity even if it was slightly
confused and off I I belonged somewhere
to someone and I remember in Lebanon
like sometimes I walked down the street
and Beirut and people know who my
parents are because I look like them and
that's the kind of place it is it's like
a village you know this is the
neighborhood that this family is from so
this must be their daughter and I never
had that before and it was just so so
nice to feel connected and routed to
somewhere